hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on for honor again and yeah
you've read by the title April Fool's
event is live for the day if you're
unaware you can click the I on the top
right to see what's going on with you
know pretty much everything that's going
to be happening for the next day but as
it says in the top right right here it
says April Fool's is here they said to
only wash the heroes in cold water we
messed up all heroes got shrunk ends
April 2nd at 9 a.m. Eastern Standard
Time so you got about 24 hours and a
little bit more than that
to play and experience these heroes and
just by the thumbnail that's shougo key
carrying his normal sized weapon so I
can't wait to see where this goes
yeah we're gonna be doing maybe a game
or two checking out some of the
characters stuff like that but yeah as
always like to be if you're doing jack I
subscribe for every new I cover the
informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes they hear
updates the Patchett's and the leaks if
you want to be kept today with
everything happening within the world of
Warner and never miss out on an update
don't be subscribe the channel and uh
let's get started with today's video
alright finally started into a game you
know what I want to go big you know I
know we already saw the picture but I
feel like we gotta go with shougo key a
because I've been playing shougo key a
lot but I mean it's gonna be the biggest
example of small character I can't make
this up anymore I can't even make up
this [ __ ] connection anymore all
right round two
alright so I
what the [ __ ] is this brother why am i
actually like why am I actually really
fast holy [ __ ] this is a [ __ ] weapon
oh my god wait I have gone beer [ __ ]
you're about to get squeezed [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] these things have way more
and I thought Yeats they make little
noises - give me your [ __ ] what
happened to the [ __ ] what happened to
thee don't you [ __ ] dare brother come
back here mates big jump ok so the
animation doesn't stick that much then
so it's only for like walking all right
not bad not bad
I understand they can't do everything
but I feel like it'd be kind of
interesting to get grabbed by like a
two-inch man [ __ ] oh my god the
executions are mini - what I can't I
can't do I can't deal with this I feel
like it's just regular running speed but
I think it's due to the fact that the
characters are so tiny I think she
goki's seems like he's running faster I
need to give this a try with other
characters like shaman for sure
this thing has way more range than I
think it does and it's kind of sad oh
yes sir
bonk big grab big guy transformed a
small guy easy
give me my elf back
yes sir bye-bye
I'm actually [ __ ] destroying right
now these things really do have a lot
more range than I think they do
[ __ ] off oh you were really far I don't
know how I feel about that
you roll extremely far now especially
with pseudo key of all people so so far
what we've deduced it seems like
executions emotes Idol effects and other
things like that seem to stay within the
same effect but in regards to doing
certain moves like bite you know any ad
with like back you know backbreaker
yeah those seem to cancel out the you
know tiny mode and it also seems like
the ladders due for some reason I'm not
sure why I can kind of understand it
that was nothing
thanks thanks you B for making a
fantastic target lock in game
yikes
go minions you're bigger than me you can
take him go on what probably shouldn't
have tank that damaged oh you're one of
those people
yikes
all right maybe the executions don't
stay so it must only be some executions
then because the the Kent's a for him
like a couple minutes ago didn't have to
change the height or maybe we see it as
that but in there like in their game it
isn't I don't know it's weird see but
this one stayed all right that wasn't
that didn't even hit him at that point
easy does it boys Gigi's alright that
was pretty good
I'm not doing too bad shoot okay I'm
pretty new what you go key at the moment
so I'm still kind of getting there but I
think this is [ __ ] great and no these
look the same or are they small [ __ ] I
can't tell if that's the same or not
they it looks like it but I don't
actually know if it is or not I've also
tried to test this in other game modes
to my knowledge like because I couldn't
get a breach I couldn't get any of the
regular game modes to work but I did try
to do this in a custom game and the
custom game didn't seem like it worked
so I it seems like at the moment it's
just the core game modes I'm assuming
you could play PvP you know P Vai all
that juicy stuff you really wanted to
but you probably can't do custom match
with their friends but I think you know
where we're going with this we need a
fast care
Derr we really got to see how much we
could push the speed something could we
play shaman you know we got that nice
little defender loadout going - I'm
liking it we go to the feets I believe
she has rush I know it's not stealth I'm
more of a big stealth dude but I think
we run this what fury width I do could
we stack fury and rush let's do it
I'm in I'm absolutely in this you know
this ain't looking too bad you know
shaman warlord black prior Centurion on
my team
we got an Orochi she dokie she'll be in
the back in and then [ __ ] and ball
torture we're just getting in large boy
right there what the [ __ ] so sent sent
punches enlarge the opponent got him
dude alright so if that if the sent
punches enlarge the opponent so it's
it's it must it seems like it's moves
that that do you know some sort of
weirder animation so the bite what about
the bite I gotta try the bite the so far
just the dodge itself doesn't seem bad
but maybe if I hit somebody it might be
weird what off bro his shoes his shield
is bigger than his player model bro what
another thing that seems extremely
unconvincing is the fact that I'm I
could still one-hit kill minions my
speed is unmatched to the untrained eye
knee room I'm gonna do the unthinkable
all right new gameplan wait what the
[ __ ] happened to me wait what the [ __ ]
what what happened to me what what Shu
go keys execution must have shot my
shoulder blades to the fourth dimension
I look like somebody that I look like a
hipster that like critiques art Oh
Watson this painting it just speaks to
me you know what I mean
all these dashes of blue and red just
give me a sense of vibrancy within the
paint all right if we could just not
interrupt my bite that would be
fantastic
oh oh you've done messed up I was
getting cocky I was getting cocky never
mind we're fine okay
we recovered we've recovered we're
getting a little cocky with it
everything has been set in motion
part one rush part two I forgot what
this feat is yeah
oh yeah that was fun yeah that was that
was totally fun yeah everything about
that was fun
yeah a hundred percent I I had a good
time uh-huh no yeah
no specific character ruined that entire
game personally like I think we were
totally it was a totally fair game for
my overall thoughts I gotta admit that
was pretty fun it's not what I expected
I think after a lot of people started
putting the context clues of what was on
the obelisk or monolith whatever you
want to call it people started realizing
that we might be shrunken down and it's
starting to make a whole lot of sense
I was pretty off the mark but I'm glad a
lot of people in the comments have a way
bigger IQ than me which and it's only
two so it's it's not that hard to pass
but anyway regardless of that it was a
really fun event honestly I think I'm
gonna be playing this a hell of a lot
more after I'm finished uploading this
video that you're seeing now so yeah let
me let me know what you guys think about
this stuff in the comments well let me
know if you've gotten to play it yet any
weird quirks or anything weird with some
of the characters like with Centurion
for example how he can punch people and
then that's when he enlarges but then
goes right back for some weird reason
let me know all that stuff in the
comments below like to be if you do
enjoy subscribe for new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being the boundless changes that here
updates the patents and the leaks if you
want to be kept today with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
and never miss out on an update that we
stay subscribe the channel
and with that take care of girls today a
peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]